one of the themes we talk about here at
the Rubin report is why it's so
important to judge people as individuals
and not as a collective you as an
individual are much more than your
immutable characteristics be they your
skin color your gender your sexuality we
are all suffering from a kind of
political PTSD time and that in fact
many people who are on the right-front
there because they've been traumatized
by really low quality dangerous leftist
thinking Holly so it's much easier I
think to be offended than to take
responsibility for your own actions
just just speak don't expect something
else to do it for you but don't don't
don't siphon it off like some wing of
government it's for you to do for us to
do especially because when you put
someone in a corner all you're really
doing is locking them down in their
belief leave them with the door open
[Music]
what what am I saying it's nuts I can't
believe I have to say this huh but I
think you have to look at the facts of
every individual case well the funny
thing about her argument is that it was
predicated on the idea that somehow
people have a right to be comfortable
it's like that's just not a right you
have in life to be able to say that I
based my opinion on my own views and
that I don't have to fit into any
particular box I find that completely
liberating
you never really own freedom we only
take care of freedom and preserve it to
the next generation that's exactly what
we do here and this is the Reuben report